the comfort that you show up in it makes
me feel safe is this like a backhanded
wait can I do this that's for real are
you guys just a nice way of saying like
you look like [__] chronically oh you
look like you just like walked out of a
shower that's not terrible okay can I
tell you guys the method to my madness
perhaps and maybe you'll understand me
as a human being much better yeah I have
in sensory issues I don't like tight
denim on my body there's certain types
of like that right there is making me my
my mustache sweat come out like that
material I don't like a lot of things
that aren't soft on my body I'd rather
because you're able to put things on you
right like I don't like things are you
coming out as autistic without no I've
been out as HSB for like years right I
have this I'm not letting you feel
special for this
I just think it's funny that she really
oh but no effort in and you just tried
really hard to put
yeah
[Music]
Julie is an FDA approved morning after
pill that helps stop pregnancy before it
starts go to juliecare.co to learn more
or find Julie at your nearest CVS Target
or Walmart today that's
juliecare.co to learn more this show is
sponsored by betterhelp find more
balance with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday hey
sluggies happy Tuesday I am on the road
you can come see me in San Antonio on
June 23rd and 24th at the LOL Comedy
Club I also will be in Philadelphia in
August at the punch line and you can see
me in Austin Texas at the Vulcan gas
company October 6th through 7th I also
have dates in San Francisco San Jose and
a lot of really cool places so go to
annieleterman.com shows and you can see
me every Thursday at
12 p.m PST and 9 A.M
over on the east coast on YouTube on
anniewood with me and Todd come check it
out hi slugs I am so happy and excited
to be back on the road sharing my crazy
stand up with all of you
um we're gonna have so much fun at these
shows I will be in New York City July
19th through 22nd I will be in DC
September 28th and Boston at the Wilbur
September 30th and more get tickets at
astronauts.com I cannot wait to have fun
with you guys this summer and this one
thank you
[Music]
do you have a mom like that too that
encourages you to like wear makeup and
stuff because I have that you don't
that's this is weird my mom
was completely
um
she raised me as a boy yeah when I would
put makeup on she'd be like you look
like a tart which is so funny in
retrospect hilarious but
um
she would never say something you like
like put on a better outfit or like you
look better but she would tell me the
truth like if I was like do I look good
and I should say no I'm like oh
I really was just looking for that mommy
lie
my mom like I told you my mom would like
put her hair in like a hat and like go
up but this is her story I think it's
the story of A League of Their Own but
she'd be like put her hair in a hat and
like go try to play baseball the boys
are like scram girl get out of here
baseball's for boys like my mom was like
such a tomboy I think none of us have
the mom lie like none of us have the mom
that's gonna be like no sweetie you're
amazing
the opposite are you kidding me more
push-ups [__] like what are you doing
why aren't why don't you look like the
specimen I am like that's exactly what
my mom would say and the worst thing
about my mom is she's always just been
like a fitness babe right but she does
this thing where like I don't know if
it's genuine or not but she doesn't show
her body she goes it's just for me and
she is ripped poor Roger he's just gotta
[__] her through a hole
Jewish lady
which she does this thing where it's
just like this is just for me and I'm
like is it you could afford to show unab
or it is like selfish it's like let us
have it yeah let me have it apply the
pressure wait okay speaking of your
mom's super fit hot body you know how a
couple weeks ago did you get a tattoo
over Mom
or a test on you
um
bulk up and then I was like wait me too
and I know it seemed like I was just
copying you in the moment but
um I wasn't and I have a theory about it
I think that because of the rise of
ozempic making it easier you know so to
speak like there's a shortcut to losing
weight I think that now the trend is
going to swing to well then the real
like Flex is being muscular and I think
muscular like I think we're there's a
reason we both randomly did they cut
your they cut your um prescription
Esther's doctor's like there's no more
Olympic for her now she's like I think
the thing is to not be on ozone I was
never on Olympic wait okay and you
didn't pay for that check mark yes
they're on Creatine doesn't feel right
though no I will not be doing you
getting buff is actually so funny that
you have to do it Esther can you please
actually you're right get on something I
will actually beat you up if you don't
get wait what is that thing that all of
these gym girls um get on just a little
bit of this because like they say like
you know like don't act like you don't
take it the gym girls do it you do it
what is the name of the thing right
Annie if I took it I can promise you you
guys would be like oh my God it's just
because like you know how steroids work
in men differently than they work in
women so women only we don't need to
take like a time I just learned this on
Tick Tock so you know like so it it just
it was taught to me that the reason all
of these gym girls are looking shredded
as [__] lately and I'm just like I'm
working so hard and why don't I look
even like a tenth shredded like that and
it's because they're taking a small
amount of what the men are taking but it
works so much better on women to like
tone them and shred them that I'm like
oh there's a cheat in that world too
there's a cheat in this world there's a
gym are their lives happy though are
people yelled at at home or like their
dog are the dogs like the dog's getting
screamed out they're not this is what I
mean like I just imagine like the gym
[__] is going to be like fight oh [__]
shut the [__] out you know what I mean
like I can't imagine it's got to come
out somewhere well that's what Taffy was
talking about she's like boiled chicken
people aren't happy like the people that
bring their own like Tupperware boiled
chicken and broccoli to a party like
that's not a happy life I can't imagine
that's a happy life I did that for I was
supposed to do like an eight-week
program that was like that I did it for
four weeks and then cluster headaches
murder you if you do this do you think
that's related
no I mean I'm always it's just different
every two years it's a different thing
so I don't know what it is what do you
think it might have been the boiled
chicken this year but it was it's a
little stressful yeah it's a little bit
to have to like count everything and I
didn't like it was a program where you
like you would like text in what you ate
it's like I just don't want to like have
another person involved no thank you
it's already embarrassing enough that my
business manager sees what I spend
that's too vulnerable it's so weird wait
I have gone for Life lately I will when
I'm scrolling Tick Tock like if someone
is doing a food thing and it's about
grams weighing any over like over
emphasized thought and work into food
like that I swipe I don't want to be on
that form of tick tock anymore like I
don't want to wave food I get it because
I know those people like that's their
lifestyle and it is working for them and
I think that's cool but I realized for
me yeah I that's too much effort and
thought into food and then too much
Obsession I need to just okay like I'll
try my best to like just eat a circle
some people like thrive in that sort of
like military idea of like full
discipline all the time like but I just
don't I I realize like I think every
time I do get my class right it's around
a time where I've been going really hard
at exercise or something where it's like
harder than is natural for my body yeah
it's like you do you whatever works for
you whatever brings you Joy in this life
for me that's super regimented lifestyle
is not it I become super disordered
um I I can't have numb numbers on my
Peloton I need to know I'm doing this
because it feels good not because I it's
like I've always used exercise as a way
to punish myself for eating a certain
meal I'm I'm done with that I'm done
with that I'm still pretty hard on
myself today but I'm like
I'm the same way scroll so fast up that
whatever macro count it's like I
understand what I'm supposed to be doing
but I choose the peaceful route the
Kinder route and the Kinder route is
just I don't need to know the numbers
like
I know how to eat well so I'ma stick to
that are we soft girlies
but not what do you mean like there's
like a soft Girl Movement on Tick Tock
and I don't exactly know what it is no
like like a song I'm the soft girl of
the group like a soft lifestyle like
we're not like Barry's boot camp anymore
like why do you feel like I've grown out
we're softer well I get sick it like
hurts me and I can't do it it's I just
did some deadlifts this morning though
so I don't know how soft I am I'm pretty
heavy okay
um I I think I'm just like a kind to
myself girly trying to be kind to myself
girly okay but no I come from a
background of like pure military hell
like that's hard to shut off so there's
still a part of me that's like Esther
like work harder oh no
wait but I do get off when you say that
okay I have a question that there's a
division in my household about this
when you buy new clothes
do you wash them before you wear them no
you wear them with the tag on four times
even pansies you have to wash pants of
course but I'm not returning my
underwear
I actually am test drive no because it
depends on the Garment
it's covered in like Warehouse debris
you think you're cleaner and your
detergents cleaner than Warehouse I
would take Warehouse over something
Washed by you any day wait you you cut
to you wear Warehouse perfume
um I wash you do wash yeah why do sports
bras or if it's bras underwear things
that have to stay on my body for a long
time I wash um I don't wash things like
a dress from
um you know like a silk dress or
something I won't watch that why not
well we have to dry clean yeah the Drake
yeah oh that's why all my silk is is not
good
I have every cashmere sweater I own is
this big now
yeah dry
cleaning is I have assumed that that was
a myth for a long time
so yeah once they came out with those
like dry cleaning bugs when I was in
college where you just put your stuff
like in the wash in a bag I was like is
this oh is that real oh no I think
that's a mark of a real adult right like
when you finally get something dry
cleaned yeah that I have yet to get
there but then you have to remember it's
there it's like oh God how long does has
that jacket been there yeah I think the
mark of a real adult who's like steaming
something like having the handheld
steamer in your home like I don't own
one like I show up wrinkled everywhere
and it's like [__] it I like being
wrinkled me too yeah it's the truth it
is the truth did you know that my mom
irons her clothes every morning before
she goes to work
yeah that's what real adults do they do
that no
what is wrong with you what what do you
do you start your pants and it does not
look that iron to be honest like it but
not that ironed like
you could have been a little wrinkled
and it would have been the same you
could have had that time to Andrea play
with your baby
are you my mommy are you my mommy wait
you really iron your clothes every day
before work yeah
a moment of silence a hush over the
crowd that is where did you learn that
like did is it something that was just
told to you that you had to do yeah I
also ironed the clothes from uh for my
wife ah my my mom taught me how to iron
and I mean Iron Andreas
yeah what items of clothing do you iron
like besides just shirts yeah mostly
shirts also pants that are you know not
Gins but like pants that would be the
fabric would wrinkle like dressy pants
or something like do you have an ironing
board yeah is it always out or do you
take it out I take it out and put it
away yeah what a nightmare I mean how
many stops nothing fancy is the way I
dress basically your worst nightmare
because everything is always wrinkled
and soft I just always wore collar
shirts so then it's like it became it's
difficult to wear this completely
wrinkled if you just wear a t-shirt I
feel it's okay yeah but if it has design
on it or like it just doesn't really
show at least maybe in my head maybe
iron there's no you notice like how many
steps it would take for me to iron like
I would have to first of all I'd have to
find the garage opener okay I'd go find
the garage opener I then have to go
downstairs to the garage I'd realize
that I forgot my phone key to the car so
I have to go back up get that I'd have
to open up I'd have to find the shirt
that's shoved on the ground in a crumple
take it back up I'd have to take out the
ironing you get a phone call 30 minute
break I'd have to put it there I have to
wake Todd up to iron it it would just
take so much and you'd probably find
like an old costume from like 60 yeah
now you're coming out like fully in it
right I'm good I'm curious will the
Slugs tell us when do you even own an
iron two do you ever use it like to me
when I think about an iron I'm just
scared that thing look you know the iron
though because one of the movies she saw
must have been home alone
we're formally taught how to iron of
course I was not
what yeah who would teach us to iron
parents come on man my parents were
doing other shows yeah they're cooler
than ironing no offense
they teach you how to like cook like to
make a bechamel baby what is this day
one our parents did not teach us
anything I don't know how to read
swim or ride a bike wait we're gonna
change I I swear I know I've been saying
this for three years on this show but I
I'm so sorry I cannot be friends with
someone who doesn't know how to swim
like I'm so embarrassed when I even say
it out wait so are you saying for three
years you're finally not friends with
her it's got to change Esther this is
the summer this is the summer of Esther
swimming I'm so sorry that this I'm not
giving you a choice thank God you waited
for her to start waxing I see her in a
bikini a couple years ago Things Are
I don't care what the [__] you wear if
you wanna I'll throw you in there naked
I don't care but you are learning how to
swim it's final and then she'll be like
an infant where you throw her in and
she'll just pop back up I actually will
do her little penis like in the Nirvana
if you both do it because weirdly I will
say this I really trust and feel more
safe with Annie in the pool than I do
with you because I think you are tough
and scary and Annie knows Annie really
knows how weak and I think I think what
you're saying is absolutely none of this
[__] has worked on me this week girl
power no she's got it she I think that
so far no drownings on my record I could
promise you that no PTSD on my record
I've never had somebody be like that was
so traumatizing I wish he had gone
slower I'm super slow methodical and we
go at your pace but you're getting in
the water fine thank you she thinks she
can manipulate me to not make her go in
I was taking it as a compliment for a
second and he'll protect me
foreign
if you've ever had unprotected sex
forgot your birth control had a condom
break or you're just not totally sure we
are excited to talk about a new company
that is giving emergency contraception a
much needed Rebrand and this is how
Julie works you guys so Julie stops your
body from releasing an egg using using
the same active ingredient as plan b or
other morning after pills essentially
Julie works by preventing or delaying
your ovulation with no egg there's no
fertilization and therefore no pregnancy
and it's no risk for future and it's no
risk to Future fertility it's legal in
all 50 states you do not need an ID
prescription or credit card to get it
and they just launched at CBS you can
also find it at Target and Walmart
across the U.S and Julie is not just a
morning after pill it's a morning after
pill brand that is working to increase
access to emergency contraception for
women across the country which is very
important right now Julie has a one for
one donation program that means every
time you purchase a Julie at a store or
online the company will donate one pill
to someone who needs it Julie partners
with over 25 organizations across the
country to provide donations to those
disproportionately impacted by Health
inequalities you can go to juliecare.co
to learn more or find Julia your nearest
CVS Target or Walmart today that's
juliecare.co to learn more this show is
sponsored by betterhelp it is so easy to
get caught up in what everyone else
needs from you and never take a moment
to think about what you need from
yourself but we when we spend all of our
time giving it can leave us feeling
stretched thin and burned out and I
always believe it's like if you don't
fill your own cup you cannot feel
someone else's you need to make sure
that your needs are met you need to make
sure that you're operating at your best
self and there's really no better way to
ensure that than seeing a therapist what
what else can you do that's truly for
you for your mental health for your
happiness to better your future then
talk to a professional what I love about
Better Health help is it's entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
they also have a journal feature on the
app where you can write down your heavy
thoughts and share them with your
therapist on your next appointment and
you can switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge I struggled so much
finding a therapist in my 20s and like
just all those hurdles parking
um just finding someone that was the
right fit for you the fact that better
help has not made it so convenient and
affordable you can do it from home you
can switch therapists easy at any time
you can find someone who's your
specialty I think if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief question
here to get matched with a licensed
therapist and switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge find more
balance with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com trash Tuesday
thank you
wait I have this new Theory I just
thought of so now that kalila is single
and she's not having to like take care
of Bobby I think how do you know that
part
foreign what are you talking about of
course I need to take care of Bobby what
that's a lifelong commitment ah well
that but it is I it's I cannot I cannot
release them into the wild well Annie
and I think that you need to so that
then you start to miss I do not agree
with you no I don't know what she's I
got no sidebar with her she says she's
adding me into less than a blow
I didn't [__] talk to this [__] last
time you saw me talk to her was the last
time I talked so that you will then
start to miss having someone to care for
and Annie and I will get the
trickle-down carings and I am a grown-up
you are a grown baby I don't need anyone
taking care of me that is you can be new
Bob that is what I'm Crown you new Bob
I'm aiming for new Bobby roll but I have
I not like you know mothered you all no
you have you have but I'm just saying
like extra mother I've seen how much
you've had to give how you've given for
Bobby and I'm like
that's all that's all you want that's it
you just want someone to hopefully
devoted to you we're gonna have to fight
him day is busy you're gonna have to
fight him because he's not letting go of
those perks is Dave like picketing more
than everyone else so he has a reason to
not take care of him he's trying to add
like dusk till dawn
and the last one we picketed yesterday
together and I was like oh my God like
Dave's taking me like it's like a date
night
it's so it sucks it's so boring and I
know it's like shitty to complain about
but like picketing is not fun and I
really want this to be over but we're
never gonna back down but
um yeah dude it's like my feet they're
all on Radford at like High Noon yeah
when the sun is just beating down on the
concrete like it well they could use a
little Sun they've been inside eating
Red Vines for the house six years
straight
I will say this though I've noticed a
very the more productive version of
picketing is like when people will pick
it outside of production because most
people who work on a production are not
going to cross a picket line and then
they shut down Productions and that like
helps the actual cause because if they
like if people are still shooting things
and it's not really affecting the
studios whatever I mean I know you're
saying if you go to like your co-workers
you're like hey Bob you really going in
yeah that's what we're apply the
pressure effective because I don't know
if you saw this but there was a shoot
and literally like three picketers died
oh shoot okay
the three it only took three picketers
to to shut a production down so it's
like not that I do think you could be
annoying enough to do it forever
everybody go home Esther's got it
don't even let me say what I think you
could accomplish then
um when you know someone's paying like
do you order less or more or who's the
person no oh that's a really good is it
my manager my agent we're going Lobster
okay that's a really good let's say
family or on Lobster I have I actually
am glad you're asking this because
I
I will not order as much if I know
someone else is paying because I'm
embarrassed and so I hate what if it's
Dave that's different his money is my
money and my money is my money
but like yeah because isn't it if you
know someone's paying I'm like scared to
order a soda but that's just like the
way I was raised because I wasn't
allowed to get sodas yeah
um
I think like if it's a if it's someone
that's putting on a company card and or
they're writing it off yeah
yeah but if it's like someone's like
coming out of their wallet and it
depends it's like when I go with Tim
Dylan he's like that's his thing is he
wants to spend the most money he can
yeah he probably like when I treat
people I really I will enjoy when they
order and they like you know to their
hearts content so I um but I I'm unable
to do that if it's someone else's tab
like I am like really conscientious and
I don't want to be because you're right
like like they probably feel the same
Joy I feel when when I treat people yeah
like when I know I'm treating I'm like
let's get this and this and this and
that's when I'm like really going all
out but I wouldn't be I would just feel
embarrassed to do that when's the last
time you treated
in New York I paid for quite a few
dinners with friends and uh are any of
them in the room that can confirm uh the
skeleton over there obviously didn't
order a lot
please or by the way there's a skeleton
with the Yankees hat on and I came and
went Esther
[Laughter]
okay if everything in entertainment
ended and it was okay you guys were
there's no anxiety about it just to be
clear you had so much money it has ended
it's over what and writers well that's
true but like all like there's no
podcast okay there's no TV there's no
like anything like that okay and that's
just how the whole world is and
everyone's readjusting but also you were
given millions of dollars and enough
money to always like be okay so you
don't have the anxiety of money what
which and you know that you could if you
try to get good at anything you get good
at it what would you try to get good at
that has no you don't need it to
entertain people and you don't need it
to make you money but could it be a form
of entertainment or no it's just like is
it you doing it
[Laughter]
um and is it just for your own personal
Joy yeah it's just like what would you
fill your days with if you had no
obligation oh mine is so easy it's so
easy it would be I would just live
underwater I would dive all day I would
swim all day because that is the one
place where my head shuts off and I feel
very meditative did you see Avatar the
way of kalila dude Bobby was just like
actually no other reason at all like
watched it for the water stuff and he
was right like I fast forward to the
water the whole thing was yeah
but that's a that's a really easy thing
for me like even when I do like EMDR
like my happy my happy place that I have
to get back to is always like water
related I don't know it just feels so
nice you should do an underwater podcast
is it scuba tanks it's just like thought
bubbles
my answer is like kind of lame and basic
but
because of all the progress I've made
over the last five years of like just
fixing my body ailments with like
physical therapy and like you would go
to the doctors
no no doctor's appointments all day baby
I would really want to like just keep
building muscle and like I just can't
accept this as well and I don't think I
don't even mean bulking I just mean like
you don't understand for like 30 years I
had no ab muscles I just had an image in
my head you know who you would look like
if you bulked up I don't want to bulk up
have you do you guys know that Little
Hercules no yes can you pull him up this
is exactly what you would look like if
you were a bulk with boobs no do you
think her boobs will go if she bulks up
young the young kid yeah that right
there like that not okay on the left oh
look at him now he's regular he's living
a regular life now come on with a long
hair on the left that's that's you
Esther oh my God look at would she not
look like that
facially maybe yes this is brand
denigration
I I would want to get focused on like
having a healthy body I'm so sorry did
you get a new so law term that you're
going to use against people
are you just waiting did you say brand
denigration yeah and then wait have you
been meeting with a lawyer
I'm in law school remember
um and then
also I would want to learn how to cook
like really
like feed myself because I've noticed
that there's a very meditative
experience to cooking and I I feel so
fulfilled by feeding myself right by
wait by the the recognizing of like oh
I'm not dependent on a restaurant is
like very empowering for me and so I
know those aren't like exciting or fun
but that's the first thing that comes to
mind like feed myself really well and
like take care of my body because I
don't have pain
yes just for yourself would you cook for
Dave too or just yourself I would cook
for Dave but we're eating what I mean
we're good Dave are you watching we're
eating what I make you don't get to
choose um is this my camera I always
look at this one wait what about you
um I would probably just do artwork like
what
um like there's like so many things I
never did I never have tried really oil
painting I've never tried
I've really only painted with like
acrylic or anything but I never do it
because I realized I was trying to think
of like why do I not draw more and it's
because I've somehow attached it to like
entertaining with it and monetary stuff
you are so good too Andy yeah you're
genuinely but I could be really good if
I practice I only draw like once every
three years so I told you it was a Benji
I came up with that one right yeah that
makes sense then she was like I was
hanging out with Benji aflallo and we're
supposed to be writing jokes and I just
got this idea to draw the Danny DeVito
thing and he was like stop drawing
you're never gonna make any money off of
that and like two hours later I made my
most profitable thing I've ever done in
my entire life
it's not that's what's good about Benji
you gotta not
wait there are people like that I think
they're just as valuable because it's
like whatever that person says do the
opposite and it works well whenever I
listen to like do you guys ever listen
to Abraham Hicks or any of that sort of
stuff there's like this this theory of
like every time you're like if you're
negative or you're or something bad
happens it's actually not bad because
it's reminding you of what you don't
want which is now showing you what you
do want it's actually putting out like
positive manifestation Vibes too because
on the other end of it and if there's
something you really really want to do
um my new life hack is to not share it
with anyone because like it kind of
serves as like internal fuel it's like
your own little secret kind of dream
that you keep and I find that the moment
I announce it I've gotten the dopamine
head and released it and I am not gonna
follow through with that plan anymore
because I've already shared my dreams
but if I keep it to myself I'm like oh
this is exciting yeah you're like I'm
excited to show off the end the end
result yeah but I never usually I won't
get to the end result if I'm just
talking and kind of already getting the
dopamine hit either or the
disappointment when someone says I don't
like that idea so like both ways is not
good for me I would rather I don't have
my old manager
came across
it's from you Esther but basically there
are men out there that are looking for a
very specific type of lazy girl have you
heard about this wait okay
let me pull up this post I found
because it's like I think it's been
circulating and I'm kind of like I'm so
intrigued by it because I'm like could
that be me I think it's all of us a lazy
girl but like lazy is obviously a myth
right but he wants a specific type okay
just there's a Post circulation I think
it'd be healthy for you to have someone
that just wants you to but I don't know
what this is yet you might be right
Annie actually I think Annie already has
it not been very lazy girl at all so
this someone sent me this they found it
on Reddit and it says I adore lazy women
I have this fetish where I prefer a
woman who does nothing all day video
games or TV or just napping all day
sounds super hot I want to be the one
working long hours to pay for them to be
lazy all day then I want to get home and
be told to cook and clean while she
continues to be lazy and do nothing I
have this fascination with lazy women
like I just want to enable all the bad
habits ideally a stoner drinker and or
smoker is this attainable has anyone
ever heard of this
but here's the thing yeah is she
supposed to be hot and fit too you know
what I mean like you can find that woman
she's 600 pounds she's on TLC right now
wait a second you're right Annie because
it's like does he just want a little sex
doll then to just [__] when he wants to
[__] but then wants to kind of just
watch and like I don't know what that is
like she this person
or is she also cruel is she just like is
she showing him attention like what is
what is the deal yeah then now it's
reminding me I don't know if you guys
saw John Mayer on caller Daddy but he
said that he wants a woman who is more
who like will just sit in his house and
like chill and he basically described a
pet cat and now I'm like is that what
this is too it's I like that part where
it's like I don't want to have to feel
like I need permission to nap or lounge
or have a super just relaxing day I'm
not even gonna say lazy because I think
we all deserve just super relaxing days
I like that part but if you're gonna
force me to do nothing that's a little
[__] excessive like that's crazy that
feels like a prison it seems kind of
like a fetishy like it would be fun for
a couple weeks you know
to be the lazy girl laying around sucks
like ever break your leg like yeah at
the end of it you're like oh God Force
if you're forced to lay around just like
yeah I just can't imagine choosing
laying every day ever that my favorite
hobby I I swear to you guys when I get
out of the shower in the morning I sit
and I just dissociate I lay and I just
this so yeah but you also do like a
thousand push-ups after for you to play
Lazy Girl is very should you be John
Mayer's cat
I'm gonna scratch the [__] out of this
ball sack did you ever were you ever on
dating apps why do I picture you of
never having been on I was on them for a
very brief okay horrific time
I went on three dates and they were
memorable
you guys I can't believe that's what
people do now no it's so weird it's well
it's Grim haven't we sort of proved that
like by now the research shows that
that's like what's ruining our culture
is that like people have too many
options on Netflix right yeah you're
like there's too many things to watch it
feels like there's nothing to watch yeah
and I know you're single and I don't
know if this is like triggering or
whatever but what is your opinion of it
I go out into the wild the last two boys
that I dated were out from the wild I
just feel like it's except
I met a I met a girl I only turned my
hinge on for girls and I swear to you
guys like I've never she is the hottest
girl
like I think I've ever seen
and but when you met her it wasn't a
Vibe right
is that what you said I I don't know if
there's just no vibe or it's because I'm
just not like you think I'm sorry so
unfortunately fluid
I'll accept whatever diagnosis but if
you don't eat each other outside
oh my [__] is and it's really really
perfect state right now it's like a
couple days after my periods ended and
the smell is intoxicating it's the most
perfect [__] scent ever it's kind of
right before ovulation it's not as goopy
but it's like oh so good you guys like I
will do this all day it smells so
[__] good yeah but it's your own
brand you need someone else to tell you
[Laughter]
they're like asleep like
hello babe but like don't do you think
that dating apps are like this whole
like myth that like people they made us
think that that's how it should be and
then they're actually so wrong because
you need to like
have eye contact and like meet the
person I think it's so weird like for me
and I I only went on these three dates
it was like very
[Music]
um
it's like there's so many layers of
disappointment involved or potential
disappointment I guess if you meet
someone and it's a vibe that never
happened for me but
um I think like you see a person
you're not supposed to see a person
you're not supposed to have all these
components like you see them and then
you also have like emails with them
basically and you don't smell them
make eye contact with them see what they
look like in public like you're supposed
to see what someone looks like and feel
if I feel if there's a Vibe or something
and then but so what happens is I'll
like see this guy online I'll create who
I think he is from his profile so I
create this character I get like really
into this character right and I'll go
real like far into the story I'm like
okay here he is music producer okay all
right he loves the hip-hop I'm like oh
he loves hip-hop this is so cool I'm
like oh I bet he wears like a nice like
flat broom hat with a little hoodie over
it so you assumed his wardrobe I start
yeah like because you know you see like
what like four pictures or whatever and
I'm like okay I can kind of like I can
use my own I can put what I want him to
be in there and kind of like mix it up
and then you
meet the person
and they're nothing like it they're into
classical music they're eating dry
cashews is their snack which is for some
reason is the least hot thing they could
possibly well it's like when they said
they were a biker was bicycles
they like wear their helmet you know
what I mean it's like um when I'm online
I'm looking for a guy that's brave
enough to get that head injury okay
I think I I always love them you go
ahead go ahead no but no but I was just
saying so then like when I meet this
person not only are they not a Vibe for
me anyway and they never were going to
be there's like a funeral I have to have
for this person I thought that they were
so I created this character and I have
to Now kill this person that never
existed who I like was totally vibing
with do you know what I mean yes versus
the opposite which is my last experience
of dating somebody it was like the first
time I met him like I didn't even clock
him as like attract just nothing there
was no feeling in my body about anything
because that's usually how it is when
you meet someone in the wild right
they're just like oh okay like it's just
a guy yeah and then you learn about them
slowly like oh like you're an artist oh
you actually ride motorcycles oh you
build motorcycle engines oh you surf oh
you're a sculptor oh like all of these
things start to build so you start from
this thing and like it's the opposite of
what Annie's talking about because then
it builds that kind of like no [__]
that's amazing and then you start to
feel that like you're impressed with you
know like they you just like leave all
that room to be surprised and impressed
by somebody yeah that versus online
dating because everything's already out
there you don't you you need everything
you need to know that you're getting
things backwards they're getting the
Hobbies first yeah and you're getting
like the way they stand yeah like
there's things that matter there's
nothing to be like there are no
surprises anymore like even if you look
at my dating profile you'll be like oh
she likes the water like that's not
something he needed to find out about me
he's like free Dives like I know all of
her Hobbies already and it would be so
much more magical I'm sure like to be in
person and hear that from you and
Discover it right there and if they
already know all your hobbies all we
have left to tell them is our rape
stories better order quick get those
apps out on the table but I mean even
that's out there if they were to like
search like one podcast episode I know
it is weird like to date when you're a
public figure too where it's like
especially on a podcast where it's like
there's so much there's so much
interpersonal
stuff going on or what do they call
parasocial parasocial yeah or social
wait okay that kind of reminds you so
this morning I took Pilates hahaha
um and I'm so beautiful at home or in a
studio in the shower in a studio I
showered before Oh before okay is that
oh really I get credit for that what
before any showering will well it wasn't
a shower it was a bath we'll take the
shower but honestly I will understand I
do understand why you wouldn't bathe
that much because bathing is such a
thing it's a pretty showers quick yes a
bath is like but I cannot choose to
stand when the option to sit is right
there yeah a bath is basically a
wheelchair shower
okay so this morning in Pilates my
teacher was like
and I love the studio I love all these
people but like she said something that
I thought was really strange like she
said oh I'm so glad that a certain
client isn't here today because they're
in this band of this song and she was
like I wouldn't want to play it in front
of them and I was like in my head I'm
like that's so weird like so then you're
like putting extra thought into not
playing a certain song
somebody famous takes her class which
I'm a pro named rapper I'm like yes I'm
like definitely name drop that's awesome
what was the band I had no idea wait you
didn't that's why it just didn't impress
you that's where you're like what the
hell is this were you like why isn't she
playing like old episodes of alone
together
that's I was like please play my my
anything like but I thought it was weird
because it kind of made me think of this
phenomenon that's like new in the last
10 years or whatever of like when you
meet someone and you know them from you
know online or maybe you know their work
or whatever I think it used to be like
how do I act like it but I think now we
know to be like oh I know your stuff
like right isn't it it's just normal I
don't I just don't live in a world
anymore where I can like pretend I don't
know or like oh I I wouldn't dare play
their song in front of them it's like no
that's cool that's but don't you think
it'd be weird if you were like working
out and then
your song came that is weird you're like
trying to focus on the thing and then
your own voice comes on well why is that
weird instructor does this but the
instructor is the one that made the
playlist so they're a fan of your work
why is that bad because now they're
putting you like okay so here's the
thing I I am I do usually very much geek
out when I know someone but I also take
a Vibe like if it's something that's
gonna like take from what's Happening
for them in that moment I don't really
do that like I don't want to like if
it's too much like if someone's like in
the middle of a conversation and I come
in like I'm not gonna go like I know not
that I'm saying you do but it's like if
they're in a class
but her bringing it up is funny okay
you're not there well how about that
that's hilarious let's say yeah and he's
right like very simply like that was
just her bragging about having a famous
which Brad guys brag how about this
you're throwing a party
you made a playlist and it's a bigger
party and so there's like friends of
friends there and someone whose song is
on one of your playlists is that the
house are you gonna go upstairs or
whatever grab your iPod in this world
you have an iPod
um that's the last time people came over
to hang
the iPod was upstairs in my room um
are you going to go up there and remove
the song from the playlist because
you're like embarrassed we're gonna go
up there and just listen to it by
yourself no seriously like are you gonna
are you gonna be like who cares they're
here they're I like their music are you
embarrassed that you like their music no
I'm tactless
so I'm a tacky [__] I just
I would like you guys if you meet fans
outside of the well when you're
performing you're expecting to have fun
they're coming to you I ask for pictures
but if you're in your regular life and
you have those people do I see people
looking at me and go it's me what type
of fun do you like the one who is like
intrusive and like you know the hardcore
fans or like people who are like oh you
know you know they know you but that's
it a little nod or do you like that
people come you know invade your space
well it depends on if they're like
invading it like
like I I do love I love when people
recognize me I think it's so awesome I
cannot pretend like I don't love that I
love it I think it's and they're always
like oh sorry I didn't want to ask for
like a picture I'm like always ask for a
picture or like I don't even care if I
look like [__] like I think it's so
sweet it's so exciting I'm glad that
like my work is connecting with people
it's like really exciting I love it if
if I'm in a conversation someone comes
up says they're a fan I'm like oh my God
thank you and we have like our moment
and then they keep talking and I'm like
hearing what's happening over here in
this conversation that I was really
enjoying I'll go like there was someone
that did that to me it was at the comedy
store so it wasn't like that crazy but
there was a woman
she would not go away and the and I had
to say the gossip that's happening
without me right now is killing me like
it's killing me right now that what's
being talked about and I'm not included
in yeah so I was like so I'm gonna need
to end this here thank you so much but
see if I was your fan in that moment I'd
be like okay let's go to the gossip
together like you're just torturing me
by telling me but she so then she came
back and tried to do it again and that's
when it becomes like that person has a
personality disorder so if they're cool
they people know they're about like
people like Regular People know their
boundaries and I think we have like
collected a very good cool audience I
haven't had too many weirdos yeah I
think occasionally I I feel the same way
I I love when people say hi I
yeah it makes it makes me so happy to
meet them in the wild I don't care what
I'm doing I'm just like happy they're
even coming and saying hello like it
means a lot to me
um but what Annie's saying like
um sometimes there have been times like
either after like bobby shows or like
even after like one of your shows if
someone's like belligerent and drunk and
yeah like not and and they get a little
handsy like that's like a big no for me
then I'm like okay
um but that's how that actually happens
like a lot some guy pulled Todd aside he
didn't say anything to me he pulled he's
like can I talk to her and I watch it I
was like oh my God my boyfriend's like
that stabbed by some guy but he like
pulled him aside and he he pulls out 100
and goes I want to give you a hundred
dollars and that's like why and he goes
I always said if I ever saw Annie I'd
give her a hundred dollars for all the
entertainment she gave me but I don't
want to bother her so I'm gonna give it
to you and Todd didn't take it obviously
but I was like Todd you owe me a hundred
dollars
um but that was like so funny and weird
it was like such a weird thing that
could have been so bad for me but the
fact that he went to Todd made it like
just funny and like I had like a perfect
a perfect interaction was I was out to
dinner it was me Dave Dave's mom and
Dave's sister so it's like the perfect
time I know it's beautiful a girl just
walked up to the table and was like I
just want to say like I love your tick
tocks keep doing what you're doing and
then walked in I was like that was so
perfect like because also to give a
little encouragement is nice and it was
quick and it was in front of like that
was the dream I know it is funny there
was like they're always like just keep
going you're almost there
where am I going
don't give up I know they're like look
it looks like you're about to this could
be the last one ever time
yeah I know when we were in Atlantic
City with Todd's parents I just knew it
was like we were getting our car I was
like it's gonna happen it always happens
like I'm always like it's always the
perfect time it's always when people are
around when I was in Costa Rica on my
breath work thing I got recognized that
was [__] cool you know what the the
greatest feeling ever was being
recognized when I was in a small island
in the Philippines like in my home yeah
because I always imagine like podcasting
is just like a big
um you know American thing right
um but someone's like wait like as I was
like going through this tiny little
alley to go this tiny little beach and
this island is like you guys like not a
lot of people and it was a Filipino guy
it wasn't some American or some
Foreigner who like you could maybe like
assume like oh they listen to Just
podcasts and they travel you know
there's a Filipino guy that lives there
and he was like wait koyla I was I was
like wait what what if it was like one
of your bro like I banged you I'm your
brother
your own people are like proud of you
they're like no like I love that you're
doing this I'm like oh my God but I'm
like tacky braggy like name drop you too
so it's like if someone does that to me
and no and people have just like walked
into there I'm like wait here for one
second guys come back here for a sec you
tell them what you just said I ain't
above it no that's of course whenever
anyone like at the comedy stuff they're
like oh my God you're my favorite I'll
get Polly sure I'll be like Polly
I like Emily I totally forgot I've
blocked this one out but one night in
New York me and Dave were getting frozen
yogurt and we walk out and this really
young cool guy goes he walks up to Dave
he goes
oh my God aren't you a very famous actor
and Dave just goes like no and keeps
walking and I was like well he's on the
show love and the kid's like yeah and
then like I was like I'm a comedian and
he like did not even hear me did not
even care like I jumped in a pool yeah
oh my God no I didn't jump in a pool
someone tried to get me two and like oh
my God they wrote that for you
it's a documentary
and and
um yeah it was just so funny that Dave
got recognized as a very famous actor
Dave's like I'm like Dave you should
have told him you're in love he's like
I'm not a very famous actor I'm like but
the kid is confused like yeah that's so
funny to say it like that too
um okay so
um recently it's been brought up to me
that um
men often feel the burden of getting
hard
and this was the context was oh wait
what was the context oh we were like you
know when it when men
um look at idealized photos of women you
know they are they can become less
attracted to their Partners but that
it's not the same is not the true for
women women can look at like attractive
dudes and still feel attracted to their
partner but then the dudes the way they
um kind of defend themselves in this
situation it's like no like we have to
look at more images
um than girls do because we get
stimulated visually and we have the
burden of actually getting an erection
like like kind of like they have to show
proof of like does that make sense no
that's their that's the defense you guys
I'm just saying like they're like so
there are men out there who feel kind of
pressured by the the burden of an
erection okay then stop looking at like
stop desensitizing yourself and stop
jerking off too tight and stop like
looking at hot girls on Instagram like
they're doing it to themselves that's
like me saying like I ate too much ice
cream sundaes and so like I don't I'm
not I can't eat one I can't have my
dinner it's like that's my fault
that's my fault
that's actually really good that's not
mommy's fault
is that where you play mommy mommy son
right no I agree with you I think it's
like so yeah why are you looking you
have to look at all these other girls
it's just like you don't have to do [__]
what do you what is your no I think I
agree it's like if if it feels like
there's a burden for an erection you're
maybe over stimulated like maybe you
need to [__] scale back they got meds
for that too take a [__] a BC we're
not saying you know you're right there
is
you're right there is no more burden you
there's everything to support male
erections yeah but hold on how do we
feel about a man needing to take a pill
to get hard for us well if that's what's
happening that's what's happening it's
the truth
okay what are we gonna do
yell at him
how do you genuinely feel though when he
goes soft on you Midway I go he must be
having some emotional problems because
it ain't me
wow you're so healthy Annie like I told
I I for the longest time I would take it
like personally like when I was younger
not anything yeah I know it's like I
feel like when you're just like banging
to please them anyway yeah yeah
Esther no one's gone soft Midway I think
that's happened and that is very tragic
feeling when it happens you it's what do
you say how do you comfort them in that
moment you're like it's all like this is
my script my script is someone you know
I can see that they're feeling they were
very hard and sometimes they like Edge a
little bit too much so now they can't
like get it but whatever whatever it is
they're laughing because they know
exactly what I'm talking about oh my God
because you try to delay the calm and
sometimes when you do that too much you
cannot kind of keep it as hard anymore
or you right
this is
HR
well that's happened to me and and I
what do I say okay so sometimes the
nipple clamps on them are too hard I
guess the duct tape around them is I say
like hey let's just make Outlet let's
just like hang well also it's like for a
second if something is like mentally
happening to them right it's like
if it's someone you know like I've been
in situations where it's like you're you
don't want to like bug them either
because they're having like a thing it's
like their issue or whatever
so sometimes I'm you know it's like we
can just like do it later or whatever
it's not a big deal what do you say in
that moment though
all right I'm trying to think because
there was a thing with a guy I I'm
like no we have a CH I mean if this is
ever a problem making a checklist like
if you watch porn like you need to in
the moment after his dick is going soft
and you're giving him a check pack your
bags she opens her side drawer she pulls
out the list she's already reading yeah
she goes check off the ones that are
applicable yes you fill out this form
and we'll have a conversation afterwards
what do you guys like what would you
like to hear in that moment where you're
like [__] like I really do want to have
like I'm attracted to this person but my
dick's not cooperating like what's a
nice thing to hear from a girl
So Married look how married
I'm I was
I mean you guys have opened up uh my
sensitivity but
I was you know raised very Catholic and
in not I mean I went to a non-school
until I was 14 so like this topic just
never you know has always been more like
a private thing like you since I met you
I'm obviously Bobby and Andrew and
talking about it so publicly like I
think it's very healthy but it's like I
I have you don't have to yeah wait you
sound like Dave
I totally I just want to support you in
this moment that Dave thinks it's
absolutely insane the way we talk so
you're not like alone right
um I do want to say though if you fill
out my checklist and I find that you're
not guilty I will help you then you know
if this is not your fault then this is
the same if you can't help them
we'll cross that bridge when we get
there but if you are abusing yourself
and it's your fault and it's not just
natural aging or what if they blame you
for the using the cheese grater
my teeth
but what happened if it's the opposite
uh uh meaning like if you guys for
whatever reason you also could be in the
middle of it and be uninterested yeah
well we're used to that yeah we just
power through and then we just like get
it over with and I'll say something when
I want him to just come so fast I'm like
come inside me and then Boop it's done
and then I'm like oh thank God you know
I couldn't have lasted 30 seconds longer
I didn't want 30 seconds more of that
it's just like there are things that we
do to just kind of like get them there
faster so we just we're done but
thankfully I haven't had to do that in a
long time because like I actually like
sex with people now but I am learning
fancy to kind of tone it down a bit and
um speak in a more generalized way
because
um I've just been so true trained to
specifically talk about Bobby and all
like the very like you know like the
details that we would go into I just
can't do that anymore with a partner
I'll never find another partner
not that I'm seeking I'm fully okay
being alone but just like I have to
relearn do you think she was about to
cry just then no I misread and then you
were totally fine
your voice quivered but it wasn't that
and I was and I was completely okay but
I do think it is remarkable like the
person you were with Not only was like
so open but like didn't doesn't listen
to this show so you could just say
anything and that is such a luxury and
it's it makes you a great podcaster like
well the freedom does Dave listen to the
show because he wants to make sure you
didn't say anything bad sometimes I
think I think he doesn't listen all the
time but I think he sometimes listens
for both of those reasons yeah and he
also has like his own career people that
think that anonymity is like virginity
you know you only lose it once and then
that's it
yeah I didn't value my virginity either
though so so
what would your anal virginity be if
it's about anonymity
when people tell whether you're doing
fancy this is a
[Music]
I might be a helicopter parent
explain
um so when I have to leave my children
my dogs my pets when I leave town
I leave a [__] Bible for my pet
sitter with pictures and like pages and
pages and pages of instruction about the
tiny little things that Remy likes this
please don't pick him up when he's fully
like insane detail and I'm like oh like
I'm gonna be an insane parent I think if
I do this with my dogs I think that you
do this with your dogs and would not be
like that with human children and I am
rejecting because I do still think that
all of us will never love our human
children as much as we love our dog
human children and so I don't think you
have to worry but I I love that you're
that detailed and if I was your pet
sitter I which I hope soon one day to be
I would love that much detail Julia will
[__] rip YouTube
hidden camera please there better be a
ring camera do you remember when your
dog had talked to him
well he's the funniest thing that's ever
happened in our entire friend her pepper
just attacked I was like can you night a
dog
pepper is so bad
I think the way you are with jewels will
be the way you are as a parent
I do ask her that I always get like an
end of year assessment for her
how was I as like a person in your life
like things I could improve on really
I don't want to scar her I'm so afraid
of like not doing right by her
I understand how you thought I was
crying I'm just congested it was just a
moment where I was like oh my God I
didn't think you were going to be this
like emotional about the thing you were
I don't remember what you were talking
about but I was like and I wasn't sure
if I was the only one that was like
gearing up I think it was like anal
virginity
no but I I'm so scared of [__] her up
so I think helicopter parenting is
totally yeah I'm just trying to think of
like of course it's like your dog and
your dog can't speak they can't tell
anyone what they want what they need
what they think but you know because
you've lived with them I'm just trying
to think of like with parenting what I
don't know what the right type of
parenting would be with kids but I think
the number one thing with jewels that
I'm most afraid of is that like
like I never want her to feel like she's
walking on eggshells because I walked on
extra list my whole life nailed on them
too true and rock salt like I never knew
like what version of my mom I was gonna
get that day was I gonna get a kind mom
was I gonna get an angry mom and I was
really afraid of that so like the one
thing I always ask her is like am I
consistent in my moods if I take things
out on you and it's like undeserved and
so those are the things like I'm just
hyper like aware of because I don't want
to do that to her yeah scary I had an
ex-boyfriend that was like his mom was
had some personality disorders but he so
when he would get like hit he would get
hit for like no reason out of nowhere
so he was [__] crazy like I mean he
was like so erratic because there was
never like uh not that you should beat
your kids but there were it wasn't like
a discipline beating it was like she'd
just be pissed about something yeah and
that's how you better have nothing to do
with what was happening that's also how
you build empaths right like
empaths aren't born they're made because
you have a kid in a very like
inconsistent environment so they have to
almost like keep track of the tiniest
little shifts and people
so because there's an implication to
their safety this she did this thing
with this eye and I think a bad mood is
right around the corner and I'm gonna
pay the price she's gonna come after me
so I'm gonna clock this so you become so
[__] aware of every little thing and
it terrifies you and I think that's why
like you know unfort people like oh
being an empath is so great I'm like no
that's that was a sad journey to get
there right it was a very terrifying
Journey it has a bad origin story it
really does and it's I think it's a
superpower but it can also be a curse
because then you read into things that
maybe like don't need to be you know
read into yeah but
um I know like someone if someone does
like the smallest little thing and then
you internalize it and you're like that
meant this and Dave will always say to
me like you can't read people's minds
like why are you thinking that that
little thing like you you can't read
anyone's mind so stop don't try I gotta
say
about all that like my parent my dad was
so angry when I was a kid and so like
verbally abusive and so just really
really really had anger management
problems but he did so much work on
himself
and um
it's like so cool to have been able to
like have this whole life with my
parents where they've like evolved out
of these things we've been able to like
talk things out and stuff that it's
weird when I get when that core wound
gets triggered again it's so weird
because I'm like I've already healed it
with the person that it started with
it's weird that that's still there do
you know what I mean
yeah it's like you'd think that would
just like go it doesn't it really
doesn't and if you think about like how
like the stages of wound healing like in
real life like when you get a cut or you
know like a deeper wound say for
instance like there's it it's it gets it
looks worse before it finally heals
there's a point where you're like is
this infected or is this Scar Tissue
building I kind of like think the same
of like inner wounds where it's like it
almost feels like oh God like it's I
can't tell if it's getting better or if
it's just
um
like opening up or becoming more
infected like I can't tell sometimes
that's what I always say when I'm
cleaning my room I'm like it's gonna get
worse before it gets better you know I
gotta put everything out on the floor
and yeah
if you were tan I think you would look
so ripped right now well I will never be
tan because that's not good for you
to get sun and you don't get itchy from
spray tans are you saying that because
you see me just itching nonsense I've
literally been going in every hole of my
pants I'm literally like in my going my
[__] to itch my leg hey you don't get
itchy do you as I've been itching
wait no I don't think that's what's
making me itch I think it's because I
got I honestly think it's my waxing that
is making me itch I'm on like the third
week since I waxed oh because you
accidentally growing back and now it's
[__] I cannot do spray tans because I
just there's that period or like a
couple days after which is so dry and
itchy you also were born naturally with
that kind of not to be racist a spray
tan the Lord spreads no but in the you
know Olive Asian complexion in the thick
of the winter sometimes I'm like don't
forget no but at least that I know
you're not always my sister is Olive I
think I'm like right underneath Olive it
depends because I think I'm pale Olive
Oh Olive
no or my yellow
I'm not yellow we're not yellow you're
not jaundice no
like are we the same no we're talking
about like makeup right I'm white like
you're a pale but but I'm waiting I have
I can't we can't do this you have a
spray tan right now yeah well it's like
an old one huh you guys thank you so
much for listening we love you let us
know if you iron your clothes that's
actually really important to me
um and we'll see you next week don't
forget to subscribe and share and uh
we'll see you next week with a brand new
episode
bye guys
[Music]